a gente tem a guarda compartilhada das
nossas duas filhas
cada dia um leva para a escola o outro
dá banho no final de semana hoje a gente
passeia junto ou se mais precisa viajar
eu fico com as meninas a gente tem agora
compartilhada mas já é casada
a gente está casada há 14 anos que não é
fácil
nesses 14 anos em alguns momentos houve
um desequilíbrio eu brincava com as
meninas e dava banho nas meninas até
trocava a fralda das meninas
eu trabalhava e não entende por que eu
chegava em casa ea minha esposa estava
tão estressada porque ela reclamava fã
afinal de contas criar filhos é tão
fácil
durante um tempo era assim eu acordava
amamentava preparava o café trocava a
fralda a preparar um lanche da escola
lavar os uniformes e no intervalo entre
uma tarefa e outra entre guardar um
brinquedo e arrumar o armário eu fazia
uma entrevista é responde a um e mail
preencher um relatório porque eu nunca
parei de trabalhar e obviamente eu
ficava super cansada tava lá preenchendo
uma planilha com ouvir uma musiquinha e
pensava cara que nos cresça a a à
máquina de lavar roupa só escutava
começar quatro pessoas em casa só eu
escutava aquela musiquinha avisando que
estava na hora de pendurar roupas e
obviamente durante o dia eu estava muito
cansada muito estressada aí chegava de
noite a nossa filha mais velha ela noiva
brincar e eu pensava em gente tudo o que
eu mais queria era tomar um banho e
me dê preferência assim a obra com mais
ninguém
mas é o dia de amanhã longo não tinha do
dia apitava meu celular marido tem uma
reunião vamos trabalhar até tarde
depois vamos tomar uma cerveja com não
sei quem não sei aonde volta não sei que
ora eu chegava em casa e dizia mãe no
domingo tem mais filho é tão legal ter
filho vão ter dez filhos porque não é
você que grávida né porque não é o homem
que tem a vida profissional prejudicada
não é o homem que perde o cabelo quando
lamenta que se enche de estria na
gravidez
o homem é muito diferente é o que é uma
mulher com dois filhos no mercado de
trabalho gente vai falta quando felipe
está doente toda vez que tiver uma
reunião às seis da tarde vai entrar em
pânico
já o homem não é a mulher à imprensa
local que não o homem é um cidadão
responsável e eu confesso que
eventualmente utilizei de um expediente
que os homens usam muito quando estão
trabalhando ea mulher está cuidando do
bebê quer dizer assim quem me thera eu
poder ficar em casa cuidando das minhas
filhas
enquanto você sustentasse a casa eu
estou lá no escritório pagando as contas
da nossa família o que era uma mentira
mas quando o homem fala isso ele está
mentindo eu me tire ele estava
trabalhando pela família estava
trabalhando por mim pela minha
realização profissional
eu tenho um time que tem filho eles
estão lá trabalhando até as 9 horas da
noite mano acabou na semana vai para
casa cuidar do seu filho eu não to drink
se mandar um e mail quem trabalha
mentira está no facebook mã o que ele
está fazendo é fugindo daquela creta são
aqueles primeiros dias aqueles primeiros
meses aqueles meses complicados ele está
passando a bola empurrando para a esposa
aquele final do dia em que dá comida dá
banho pra dormir
é cansativo é desafiador e o nosso
conforto é ficar no escritório
está entendendo é por isso que muitas
vezes o marido de vocês que o nosso
filho do escritório se preocupa com
dinheiro nem é quem trabalha mais para
comprar um apartamento maior do nosso
filho pra pagar uma creche uma escola
melhor pra você é um lugar de conforto
dele é por isso que o seu marido quando
nasce um bebê vai pro banheiro finge que
está com dor de barriga 30 minutos no
banheiro não fala com vocês é esse o
cara fica lhe atingindo está fazendo
como é não tamanho ele está fugindo
aquela treta que está logo ali fora com
o bebê ea gente lógico que tem vontade
de sair correndo muitas vezes vocês
acham que toda mãe não gostaria de ir
para um congresso e salvador e vou
voltar dali um mês e falar o que saudade
caramba como crescendo esses nessas
fofurinhas gente quem está no escritório
muitas vezes está de folga e quando
chega em casa super feliz depois uma
cerveja com os amigos falando que quer
ter 10 filhos
eu sinto falta de incentivos eu sinto
falta de incentivos de sinais sociais
para que os homens entendam o seu papel
na família
eu acho muito esquisito não ter fraudado
um banheiro masculino né
não precisa ter perdido para nenhum usa
mas por um fraldário masculino vai
mostrar para os homens o mano isso aqui
é seu trampo também você também fez essa
parada
eu acho muito esquisito que todas as
bonecas das minhas filhas não falou
papai
as bonecas as bonecas delas só uma mãe
me dá um abraço
mamãe troca minha fralda uma mãe tô com
frio nem uma boneca fala papai mais um
recado o homem não precisa fazer isso ou
quem paga a conta
mulher cuida da casa e pra mim é pior de
todas a licença paternidade de cinco
dias
dá pra fazer alguma coisa uma licença
paternidade de cinco dias da deixar sua
esposa com depressão pós parto em casa e
você ficar enfurnado no escritório
trabalhando de novo reforçando a ideia
de que você é um pagador de contas
reforçando a idéia de que você é
meramente um cara que precisa trabalhar
enquanto a mulher cuida das crianças uma
ideia precisamente equivocada
eu defendo que a licença paternidade
deveria ser
seis meses para os dois licença parental
não paternidade maternidade como em
alguns países evoluídos porque está
falando pro cara você participa também e
eu falo para os meus amigos eles dizem
não e onde estão loucos se fosse
obrigado por isso o chefe vai achar que
eu não quero trabalhar que eu tive filho
só para não trabalhar e eu digo pra eles
querem então exatamente isso que sua
esposa passa toda vez que ela engravida
não é quantas empresas eu já ouvi da
boca de amigas a não vou contratar
mulher porque mulher grávida
até parece que a gente tem filho para
ficar quatro meses em casa descansando
gente filho não é descanso contra a
outra e assim a gente vai se enchendo de
culpa né
aí você a mãe se sente culpada porque
não voltou imediatamente para o trabalho
ou então se sente culpada por que não
amamentou até os 18 anos ou não
conseguiu ter um parto natural ou se
livrar daquela barriguinha ser mulher
não é fácil a gente é cobrado o tempo
todo para ser magra bonita gentil
elegante inteligente sem ser agressiva
sexy sem ser vulgar ambiciosa sainz e
gananciosa e quando a gente é mãe
multiplica por mil
a gente tem que ser super bondosa tem
que ser um exemplo amorosa paciente
a gente tem que olhar a agenda todos os
dias fazer lanches saudáveis e está
sempre disposta transar assim a gente
reclama o que a gente é maluca acontecer
pm
talvez a gente estava discutindo e aí eu
não estava concordando que ela estava
falando eu falei eu acho que também é
louca a minha filha pequenina olhou pra
mim e falou pra isso é gaslight gás
light sim é quando o homem desqualificam
os sentimentos
levo uma discussão e aí fica impossível
de começar porque o homem ao são ea
mulher a doida
você está de tpm esse momento os homens
receberam esse aval pra desqualificar os
sentimentos interromper a gente quando a
gente está falando ou explicar o óbvio
como se a gente não soubesse bom por
essas e outras questões que nós optamos
por como única saída é ter a guarda
compartilhada das nossas filhas porque
eu entendo que eu não sou 100%
responsável por tudo eu preciso
compartilhar esse com quem ajudou a
fazer e algumas pessoas falam meu marido
me ajuda né e não ajudar a dividir né
mas mesmo tempo dividia me complicado
porque como é que a gente vai saber 50%
e 50% o que eu faço troca metade das
fraldas foi de metade do tempo não
existe na verdade é uma temática não é
essa
a matemática é 100% cem por cento se
você está dando menos do que você
poderia dar para sua família para o seu
filho para a criação pra estar de fato
na sua casa sendo um agente
transformador
você tá sendo aquém do que você poderia
ser por isso eu tenho um recado bem
ratinho para as mulheres mulheres parem
de se achar culpados por tudo deixem o
pai a sobra o sogro a professora
participar da educação e dividiu afeta a
criação de seu filho quanto mais gente
participar e dividir afeta tarefas
educação mais feliz e autônomo vai ser o
teu filho e de quebra você também vai
ser mais feliz mais tranquila mais
realizada
vai ter tempo até para sair com as
amigas vez quando homens não perca essa
chance quando você tem um filho você tem
a chance de se desconstruir ser mais
sensível e mais atento de aprender o
tempo todo com aquele ser sim que está
do seu lado e não ficar enfurnado no
escritório achando que você só um
pagador de contas você não é menos homem
se você ajuda em casa você não é menos
homem se você cuida do seu filho você é
mais homem
quando você prepara um filho que entende
que deve participar e que deve crescer e
talvez formar uma família e essa família
que a guarda compartilhada dos filhos
seja no casamento fora dele
muito obrigado obrigado
[Aplausos]